c'est un ministre des finances peut être
soulagé ou même surpris qu'on va
retrouver à montréal éric girard merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté l'invitation
bonjour alors le québec c'était la
province avec le taux de chômage le plus
élevé en avril mais là on connaît aussi
le l'avancé le rebond le plus rapide on
est même passé sous le taux de chômage
l'ontario comment est ce qu'on explique
ça c'est vraiment le phénomène du
confinement et du déconfinement alors
nous avons permet 40% de l'économie
pendant huit semaines et à partir du
mois de mai on a vu les effets positifs
et maintenant juin avec de 250 mille
emplois c'est à dire qu'on aurait péril
au 2 février avril nous avions perdu
près de 800 et 1000 emplois et ont alors
récupéré maintenant 480 c'est excellent
il faut oui est ce que ça vous étonne
justement la vitesse à laquelle le
déconfinement s'est traduit en
réembauchant en impact sur l'emploi
c'est à dire que moi j'espérais un peu
de franchise avoir récupéré 50 % des
emplois perdus en date de ce matin et on
est autour de 59% alors les chiffres
sont légèrement supérieurs à ce que
j'anticipe effectivement ça se passe un
peu mieux que prévu
bon il ya quand même d'aider les emplois
qu'on n'a pas récupéré évidemment je
pense entre autres aux étudiants il ya
les femmes aussi qu'ils sont plus
touchés les besoins fonds ou en ce
moment de ce gérant
c'est à dire que tous les secteurs qui
vont avoir des impacts plus durable on
parle de la restauration de tourisme la
culture le commerce de détail
un petit peu de fabrication mais mais
principalement les secteurs mentionnés
sont les secteurs qui vont des impacts
qui vont durer lui est plus longue que
simplement le confinement des confirme
cela dit même si ça s'améliore
aujourd'hui les chiffres monsieur gérard
c'est ce qu'ont erreur de crier victoire
il y en aura donc des mises à pied il y
aura d'autres fermetures d'autres
faillites peut-être même à l'automne
avec la fin progressive des mesures de
soutien vous prévoyez quoi pour
l'automne je pense que juillet demandant
chiffres d'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas le
bénéfice de la restauration et des
centres de chou dans la région de
montréal
juillet devrait être un autre chiffre
positif qui devrait nous amener est du
disposant de taux de chômage qui est ce
que nous anticipions c'est à dire que au
mois de février
le québec était au plein emploi avec un
taux de chômage de qui avoisinait 5 pour
ça et là après confinement déconfinement
on devrait au taux de 10 % c'est-à-dire
qui aura approximativement 300 mille
personnes qui étaient à l'emploi en
février qui ne seront pas autour du mois
de septembre ou de la fin d'année et
c'est là on doit aider ces gens là au
niveau de la formation en entreprise ou
au cégep à l'université professionnelle
aider ces gens là à se replacer dans des
nouveaux secteurs tels que la santé les
sciences de ville
l'informatique est de ces gens là à se
former pour évoluer vers des secteurs
plus permettant cette menace des
finances monsieur girard vous n'êtes pas
sans savoir votre homologue monsieur
mono avait pas de très bonne nouvelle
pour nous cette semaine avec un déficit
nettement plus important que ce qu'on
prévoyait au québec on voit ce
déconfinement s'accélérer mais en
progression de l'emploi est ce que ça
peut avoir un impact sur vos estimations
pour les déficits
je vous dirais que présentement on est
les semis nous avons donné autour de 15
milliards la wii est toujours bon il ya
quand même beaucoup de marge d'erreur
mais le déconfinement se passe bien
aujourd'hui on a une nouvelle positive
on aura probablement une autre
amélioration en juillet c'est après
qu'on va devoir venir avec des mesures
d' aide à la formation aux entreprises
au développement économique
et bien sûr l'infrastructure j'avais
tout à l'heure vous avez dit les les
restaurateurs ne sont pas satisfaits les
propriétaires ne veulent pas tous
participé au programme de loyers
commerciaux mais je vous rappelle que
dans le projet de loi santé un élément
de mesure anti éviction pour inciter les
propriétaires à s'entendre avec encore
faudra-t-il l'adopter on verra de quelle
manière mais sans suisse à l'automne
merci beaucoup monsieur gérard mais je
vous remercie
abba